Curtis Leewood thanks for joining us
you've been arrested a few times
standing up for the city people and
these uh against the illegal immigrants
not them personally but they don't
belong here no it's an invasion how do
you describe it as anything other than
an invasion at invitation let's go with
me a full year Governor Abbott said no
much no much we can't handle this he
said I have to bust them to the
sanctuary cities and Sanctuary states
which mine there is no law that says
these cities and states are Sanctuary
it's a proclamation that can be
rescinded in a second and who stood in
front of Governor Abbott with his five
thousand dollar customized old Silk suit
Eric Adams swag a man with no plan
called him a racist said Bring It On
send me all of the illegals and we'll
put them in hotels give them three
squares a day iPhone smartphones health
care and now all of a sudden he realizes
he's been overwhelmed and instead of
instead of apology
we saw Governor hokel just say now I
understand he doubled down on him he
said this monster who keeps sending them
to New York and what did Governor Abbott
say okay I'm going to double the number
that I sent to New York City and the
fact is it's only been 35 000 we have
had over a hundred thousand so they're
coming on their own within two weeks
they're going to be in our borders again
but you stood up for the people that say
you can't put them in a senior center
you can't put these into school this is
our neighborhood we don't know who these
people are they might be the best they'd
be a bunch of Einstein so they could be
a bunch of gang members we don't know
what was it like on the ground I'm
seeing some of the video of you in the
middle of people and you got arrested a
few times the talk about the emotion of
the people of New York oh it's we're
beside ourselves because we feel our
elected officials have abandoned us to
support illegal aliens they have drones
in our rallies do you imagine if this is
like Orwell 1984. why are drones spying
on people who are practicing our First
Amendment right of free speech and then
they make Mass arrests of us meantime if
you're an illegal Brian you have no
curfew if you happen to be a veteran
down on your luck and you're staying in
a nearby shelter as an American you got
to be in at 10 o'clock at night these
illegals are going up and down with with
all kinds of mopeds and electrified
bites none of them registered none of
them license they're drinking salvation
they're smoking weed these are military
aged young men who may be escaping their
countries because they don't want to
serve in their military and they're
coming to Times Square New York City is
their choice destination because we
promoted it as such and they're trying
to Reign it in now Governor Cuomo of all
people disgraces he is came out and told
Kathy hokel Sue Joe Biden number one I
don't know we're not lawyers but is
there grounds to Sue and since what is
he anti-bitant of course and by the way
this is the same Cuomo when he was
riding high in the saddle called
islamigre immigration Naturalization
Service our federal law enforcement
agents started after the attack of 9 11
thugs he didn't call MS-13 touch he
called them Dutch he can't have it both
ways we have to support lamigra
Immigration and Naturalization and most
importantly ice when does it end 15 of
every agency's been cut including cops
and firefighters they now have cut 75
percent off the anti-terror force they
kept us safe since 9 11. when does it
how does this end very simply Eric Adams
has to go down to when the buses come in
and say look stay here use the
facilities we give you a box lunch we're
sending you back to your papa Chulo the
one who invited you Joe Biden the
National Mall plenty of room for 10
Washington plenty of room for tents but
they have to go back if they want to
come in they got to do it the legal way
you know who's most angry at this real
quick first generation uh immigrants and
African-Americans who feel they have
been or forsaken by this
African-American mayor Eric moms and
dads who send their kids to school and
they finally places overwhelmed with
kids that don't speak English I love all
kids but it's not fair to these kids in
New York or in New York Curtis thanks so
much all right he keeps getting arrested
for the cause you're gonna put up my
bail money I'm gonna have to somebody
because you used all your other friends
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else